- Does my hair look beautiful though?
- [Mark] Your hair looks beautiful.
- Okay, do my titties look right?
- [Mark] Everything looks right.
- Tell me Mark, you think I
can knock a boy off right now?
- [Mark] I know you can.
- I'm like geisha girl,
like I just like to see
if I could do it still, and
I'm like I still got it.
- [Mark] You still got it baby.
- [Martina] I still got it.
- [Mark] All right, Martina.
- [Martina] Yes.
- [Mark] Martina, where'd you grow up?
Where are you from originally?
- I am from Sacramento, California
in Northern California,
raised in Sacramento, met Kenny Red.
He's a Bay Area cat.
So that brought me to the Bay Area,
that's where I got a lot of
my money from San Francisco,
all up and down the coast of California.
I got money all over the world,
but just starting in the game
all up and down the coast of California.
- [Mark] All right.
And tell me about your family.
You had both your parents
when you were young?
- Yes, I had both of my
parents when I was young
and, but my father,
my mom and father split up,
but my mom worked like three jobs
but I had two other
brothers that were pimps.
So, I was exposed to the game
to the ism at a young age,
and I learned how to speak
ism, real early in the game.
And I always knew to break on a boy
like don't ever let a boy
kiss you or have sex with you.
If you get money from them
they won't tell nobody,
but it sounds crazy.
But when you're young
and you're absorbing all kinds of game
from your big brothers telling their girls
you know what I'm saying?
Their hoes, certain things,
I'm getting all the game,
I'm absorbing it all.
So yeah.
And
it's in me, not on me.
- [Mark] What age did you
start doing this kind of work?
- Well, I think I was in the
seventh grade is the first time
I gave a boy a kids for $50,
but I was 20 years old when I started,
getting down and getting down.
But I'll always been the type,
like a little gold digger
when I was a young girl,
always wanted everything.
Or if you didn't have anything for me,
I didn't wanna talk to you.
- [Mark] So money is an
important part of the equation.
- Money is a very important
part of money of my life.
- [Mark] What's more
important money or love?
- Socket to a bitch pocket.
Fuck love, I'm married
to the game, purse first.
- [Mark] So, you've had
pimps along the way.
- Yeah, Kenny Red.
I was with Kenny Red
for years and he got me
from this older guy,
God bless him, he passed away.
And I was young and yeah.
Then I got with Kenny Red Pimpin
and he had like a lot of hoes.
He was like exciting, he was fun.
He was just, he was raw, he was sharp.
He was no nonsense.
And I got with him.
- [Mark] But what is the attraction
for a girl to go with a pimp?
I mean, you're giving him
all your money, right?
- Well, the reason why I did,
because he had all kinds of stuff,
he had, a lot of things.
It wasn't like I was getting
it out the dirt with him.
When I got with Kenny,
Kenny had everything,
he had hoes, you know what I'm saying?
He had thieves, he had cars.
He just had everything, and
I was just excited by it,
and I wanted to be a
part of his organization.
- [Mark] And when did you
get out of the equation?
- When did I get out?
- [Mark] What did you get
out of the relationship?
- What did I get out of it?
I got a lot of stuff out of it.
Most of all, I got some game up out of it
and a lot of intelligence from it.
I learned a lot, if it's not
a blessing, it's a lesson
and shit, my pussy made me a better bitch,
it made me a better person.
Some bitches out here fucking free
and doing all kinds of stuff.
I can go to sleep real good
knowing that I got paid for my pussy,
and I use protection on top of that.
- [Mark] So, you've had
run ins with the law?
- I have run ins with the law
and I know how to
swindle my way out of it.
And sometime I can't.
And when I cant, you know what I'm saying?
Kenny never left me in
jail, he's coming to get me.
He's coming to get all his hoes.
You know what I'm saying?
He ain't never left a bitch in jail, ever.
- [Mark] Do you have children of your own?
- Yes, I do have a daughter.
I'm 55 right now, I'm 50 fine.
I have a daughter that's 38 years old.
She is a college graduate.
She has her degrees, and everything.
- [Mark] And you raised her?
- I raised her and her father did.
And he's gone now, God bless his soul.
But she respect the game and everything
but that wasn't a path that
she chose to take or anything.
And I'll always hid it from her too,
always kept her in boarding
schools and private schools.
And she always had the best of everything.
- [Mark] So she never knew
that you were doing this.
- Oh for a minute.
But then, when she found out,
kids are smart and they could tell.
And yes she knew what it
was, but she wouldn't tripin
because I was around,
players and pimps and
dope dealers and boosters.
And we around that type of people,
you know what I'm saying, but
we were living a good life.
It wasn't like we was
living in the gutter.
We lived in the best condos,
and had the nicest cars and everything.
So she know that, it was
something jumping off
but children stay in children's place.
- [Mark] So what keeps
you in this lifestyle?
Is it that the money is good and fast?
Is it that-
- [Martina] Oh, I'm retired from that.
I'm retired from that.
I've been a Madam, I have my own stable
but not even like I'm a
pimp or something like that.
I just charge service fees for me,
accommodating a girl with a client.
So I would never put that, on being a pimp
or anything like that.
But I can say a Madam,
but getting my service fees and all that.
- [Mark] But for a typical girl or guy
that stays in this game for a long time,
is it like an addictive
lifestyle that just-
- [Martina] It's very addictive.
The game be calling your name.
It'd be like, "Martina, Martina."
But you just know,
have to know when to fold
them, when is that time.
I left out the game gracefully.
I didn't wanna be one of those people
that's just still out
there still grinding.
- [Mark] But you saved money.
- [Martina] Oh yeah, absolutely.
But I don't knock the game.
If I see somebody doing what
I used to do or whatever,
I don't knock nobody or judge nobody,
because I ate and I lived
off this money for years
and it's good money.
Ain't nothing like no hoe money,
hoe money is for show money.
- [Mark] And drugs were
a part of your life?
- [Martina] No.
Marijuana, some Hennessy
and keep it moving.
- [Mark] So how do you define success?
You think the money you make is enough
to satisfy you and keep you happy or?
- No, you always want more.
It's never enough money.
Like I'm retired, but I tell
you the truth right now,
if I walked out in that lobby
and it was a rich man, a white man,
not trying to be funny,
was about to give me some money, baby.
I will pull it over for a band,
and I'll be so quick before
you can wink your eye,
'cause I got that sunshine.
Never had a problem, satisfying a client
but never say what you
never would never do.
Like I said, if I went outside
in that lobby right now
and somebody offered me
the right amount of money
like I said, I'm pulling it over, man.
I'm getting to it.
- [Mark] And there's something
about this life that
the attraction from men,
the fact that they're willing to give you
a lot of money for what you do,
that it builds your self esteem.
- It kind of has a
vanity type of thing too.
It makes you confident.
I wouldn't say conceited,
confident, like I still got it.
Like when young boys try to get at me,
like I'm definitely like,
not like not a cougar.
I would never be a
cougar, I'm more of a fox.
If anything, they're gonna
get some wisdom from me
and I'ma brother 'em up.
I nephew 'em up real quick.
I don't play those kind of games.
- [Mark] But for everything,
that's got an upside
there's a downside to it.
What are the rough
sides of this lifestyle?
- Getting robbed, going crazy.
- [Mark] You get depressed?
- Pardon me?
- Get depressed.
The only time I get depressed
about anything is poverty.
I'm a very happy person all the time.
I'm scared of poverty.
- [Mark] Poverty.
- Yeah, I don't wanna be broke.
- Yeah.
- [Mark] What do you think
the most misunderstood thing
is about this lifestyle
for people outside of it,
it seems like a very cold-
- People, judge it and think like,
oh, we're some cruel people,
we do this, we do that.
But like in the Bible, have you ever heard
of Rahab, when she hid Joshua and Caleb,
and right before they were
gonna take over Jericho
and the soldiers came
there and they were like,
"I know that somebody's
been over here trying to,
"keep out our, seen and stuff like that."
She was like, "Yeah they were here
"and they got some coochie,
"but they went that way."
When they really went that way.
And God blessed her.
So like, I'm saying that to say this,
hoeing being going on for a long time
and it's never gonna stop.
Rahab was blessed by God.
And she is one of the people in the Bible
that has so much faith in God,
that he love her so much
as she was Boaz mother.
So God took her away from that game.
And he made her virtue woman
and she married somebody
in the Hebrew army.
- [Mark] So does it wear
on you after a while
knowing that every guy, every other girl,
every cop, every pimp,
every everyone is kind of
looking out for themselves?
- It's a doggy dog world eat a be ate.
I don't have thin skin,
like somebody who has thin
skin, they couldn't take it.
- [Mark] It's not a lifestyle
for everybody, right?
- It's not for everybody.
- [Mark] Have you seen girls
that just couldn't handle it?
- I see men that can't handle it.
You gotta have that Janae say
qua, and that's what I have.
Like I said, it's a lot
of extra ordinary people
that's in this game.
- [Mark] You recall the very first time
you did this for money?
- I can remember the first
day it was June 1st, 1985.
And I went to Frisco
and I came up on $500.
And back in the day, that's like 1500.
I thought it was hot shit.
And I was like hanging
with a group of little
white girls, Italian girls,
so I was getting really money.
I was like the black girl in the group.
So I really benefited off
being around those white girls.
If you can't beat them, join 'em
- [Mark] What was the
best time of your life?
- The best time of my life,
oh, I have so many great times.
I remember like DC when Kenny,
man we was getting so much money
that's when Marion Barry was the mayor.
When he got caught with
the crack at that time,
the police was crooked,
everybody was crooked.
All they wanted was their hands oiled.
And that was one of the
funniest times in my life.
I used to have tricks, light up.
Like I would never get
in the car with them.
I would have the station wagon
and they would look for me.
My name was Tiffany back then,
they'd be like "We want
Tiffany, we want Tiffany."
And I had blonde hair back then.
And that was one of the
funniest times of my life.
I just loved hoeing, I was
just such a happy hooker.
And then having such a good pimp
like Kenny Red, really made you happy.
'Cause he was a fun pimp.
We used to go out to dinner.
He used to take us all out
we used to go to the player's ball.
He would have big birthday parties.
And we would like, whoever's
getting the most money,
and it was like a little competition thing
with my wife in laws, but it was not bad.
It was like, honey healthy,
built your character,
and who's gonna get the rawest outfit?
But he made sure that we
all were treated equal.
And one thing Kenny Red
never did, like pimps do,
they put all their hoes
together trying to save money
and stuff like that, not
Kenny Red, not Kenny Red.
He have us all in different hotels,
like he don't like all that.
And he would just be bouncing
around from different cities.
I may be in Hawaii,
I may have a wife in law Vegas
and I might have a wife in law in Miami
or wife in law in California.
Kenny Red had his first
string and second string.
And then he had the third string
which was the Dooky booties.
But he still made them
feel good about hoeing.
They weren't really no
lookers but I was also,
I was definitely on the first string.
I was a starter
but I never warmed the bench,
just to let you know that.
- [Mark] What was the
worst time in your life?
- The worst time in my life was,
thank God I never got raped
or none of that stuff like that,
'cause I'm a riot myself.
I used to have a switchblade
in my bra, a maze here,
like I'm really pretty, but
I'm dangerous, hella dangerous.
And I know how to throw
these paws, bam, bam, bam!
But anyway, back to the lecture at hand,
the most depressed time of
my life or the worst time
of my life was when
I was on the hoe stroll.
And I got really sick and
I was scared for my life.
And I got rushed to
Queens of Angels Hospital
and I was having an ectopic pregnancy.
Could you imagine it?
Out on a hoe stroll in Hollywood,
but I'm hurting all day.
And I had an ectopic pregnancy.
And then I went to the hospital.
They did surgery on me,
this stupid doctor left
surgical sponges in my stomach
and they let me out the
hospital a week later
and then I just was really sick.
And then I had to go back to
the hospital and almost died.
So that was one of the really
scariest times in my life.
I don't really have any scary times,
like I was kidnapped by no tricks.
Thank God.
I had a trick one time, pull a gun on me.
And I was like, Oh God, like I was scared.
And all of a sudden I snatched it
out of his hand, and I pulled it on him.
I was like, you're gonna
hurt somebody with this gun.
And I opened up the door, I
was like, get out, get out.
And I just pulled a gun on him.
I had some close calls,
and I had a really,
really crazy experience.
I had shut the whole hoe show
down in Vanbruun and Phoenix.
It was a rookie police.
He try to arrest me.
And he went in the hotel to go get a room
and I looked in the glove compartment
and seen his badge and his gun.
I took it all and I hid it in the garbage
outside the hotel.
And then he got in the car
and then we pulled over
and he tried to like block me in,
but I jumped out the window
before he can get me.
Then he looked in his glove compartment
and his shit was gone.
And do you they shut the
whole hoe stroll down.
Everybody was mad at me, but
I kept it, and got on a bus
and went back to another city and stuff.
But they wind up getting
it like two years later.
I'm not gonna tell you how,
because I don't wanna incriminate myself.
But that was a crazy experience,
and I know he got demoted,
but the most part I'm a happy
and Kenny Red pimping is good,
and he was always good
to all of his hookers.
And we always had nice cars,
we always had nice places.
- [Mark] Do you ever look
back at your situation
at your life and just go,
"Man, this is so nuts.
"This is so crazy."
- It felt crazy.
Sometime I regret not taking opportunities
for music producers and movie producers
being in Hollywood and stuff.
I'm a very attractive lady,
and I have a very witty personality
and I used to get offered
so many different roles
and do to do different things.
But I was just so sprung
on Kenny Red pimping,
that was against the rules.
So I never let nobody trick
me up or anything like that.
And try to tell me, "You're
too pretty for this,
"and I can help you do this
and I can help you do that."
And I used to be like, boy,
bye, I got a pimp to pay.
And I just my mind was just
straight on paying my pimp.
So I do regret that in my life, you know
- [Mark] You've been in love before?
- Have I ever been in love?
With my daughter, with my
daughter, and with Kenny Red
I used to love Kenny Red
washed his dirty draws
and drink his dirty bathwater.
Yeah, for real he's somebody
that you could love,
he got a heart bigger than Texas.
Like he had so many bitches
and he treated us so good.
And we all knew not to be jealous.
Can't be jealous or Kenny
Red is gonna be upset.
- [Mark] Did you respect
the men that pick you up?
- Do I respect them?
Hell nah, them funky ass tricks.
I'd be nice.
You know what I'm saying?
Just to get my money.
But when they be John and I be praying
that they hurry up, I'll be like,
you funky dirty ass, funky ass trick.
This is the mouth you kiss your kids with.
Hell no, I ain't got no
respect for them, the fuck.
- [Mark] What do you wish was different
about your life?
Do you have any regrets?
- I told you me not
taking the opportunities
that I could have been
just like totally rich,
but I just feel like it
was my destiny, you know?
And it was written, this is what it is.
I'm hustle mom, that's who I am.
I'm the hoe fairy.
I sprinkle these little young bitches.
You know what I'm saying?
And let them know the game
because I didn't have
nobody to give me the game
like them, because I
paved the way for them.
- [Mark] What advice would
you give to a young girl?
- A young girl-
- [Mark] Who's thinking of doing this.
- I'll tell her to stack
her money up like Jenga.
You know what I'm saying?
Stack your money up,
buy you some Bitcoins,
just save your money, give it to big mama.
You know what I'm saying?
Stay away from drugs.
Never, never, ever go without rubbers.
I don't care what they say.
I don't care if it was the priest
saying that he don't even have sex,
he's celibate and you the first one,
don't never go without a rubber.
And that's what I'm thanking
God, I ain't got no diseases.
You know what?
I'm just suck a free, I'm
one of God's favorite.
I know I'm one of God's favorites.
'Cause I ain't never, I
got my scruples steel.
My throat ain't been slashed.
I never been took off, robbed,
but I have been tried to get took off,
but it never succeeded.
No weapon formed against me shall prosper.
It formed, I had some Mexicans
tried to take me off at one time
and I just jumped in the passenger seat
and just gouged their eyes out
and we just had a car accident.
We ran into a car lot.
And when the police came, they were like,
"You're so lucky."
They was like, "They
done kill five girls."
I was like, they wasn't about
to drive me to my death.
I was kicking and screaming.
You ain't about to drive me to my death.
We all going out, I'm going
cosmic casi on yo ass.
And that was a scary experience too.
But I walked away with no scratch.
Maybe I lost a heel, but
they didn't get my money.
They didn't get my money, you know?
- [Mark] What's the most important
lesson you've learnt?
- The most the lesson I learned
and I've seen other women do,
I'm not saying from my perspective,
a lesson that, okay
I'm just not gonna talk about nobody else.
The lesson that I've learned,
a lesson that I've learned,
drop your books, lose your lessons.
Yeah, drop your books, lose your lessons.
Can't be dropping your
books, you can't be slipping.
Like you got banana
peels up under your feet.
You gotta be on your toes.
You gotta look,
watch every way and look
ahead and be 10 steps ahead.
You can't be slow, Joe.
And that's my advice, yeah.
- [Mark] All right,
Martina, thank you so much
for sharing your story.
- You're welcome.
(indistinct)
Yes, I will.
- [Mark] And thank you so much.
That was awesome.
You did great.